fast fünf monate krieg in der ukraine
und auch heute wollen wir uns die
militärische lage im land ansehen und
wir wollen es ganz verschiedene regionen
ansehen nämlich einmal wollen wir oben
hinsehen in die region aktiv dort wollen
wir uns ansehen wie die ukraine mit
westlicher artillerie nur wenige
kilometer von der russischen grenze
entfernt munitionslager zerstört und wir
wollen das auch hier unten den süden des
landes ansehen der wichtige region sagt
fischer dort setzt putin seit einigen
wochen bereits brand munition ein brand
munition nicht etwa gegen militärische
ziele sondern gegen felder der ukraine
um die ernte zu zerstören wir fahren
einfach mal an mit den aufnahmen die uns
erreicht haben aus der region attraktiv
hier sehen wir ein munitionslager ein
munitionslager der russischen armee wo
sogenannte monakam moerser gelagert
werden und wir sehen auch hier das ist
vielleicht noch mal markiert ein oral
laster der russischen armee der
sozusagen verriet dass wir in diesem
haus hier kein ziviles haus mehr haben
so wie es früher war es ist ein kleines
ukrainisches dorf sondern dass wir
mittlerweile dort eben waffen gelagert
haben und auch hier kann man das noch
mal angucken hier sehen wir
verschiedenen ohnacker moerser
geschützte die hier stehen 1 nicht
gekümmert und eins mit einer grünen
plane darüber und geschlechter zu
erkennen dennoch die ukrainische drohne
hat diese position ausgemacht und wir
sehen jetzt gleich wie die m 777 dieses
britische geschützt was von den usa
eingeliefert wurde etwa 100 stück davon
eine ukraine hier eingesetzt wird und
dann jetzt hier den beschuss beginnt wir
sehen da das haus und wir sehen die
artillerie die jetzt hier in brand kommt
und in einigen kunden werden wir sehen
wie eine mega explosion da ist sie eine
erste explosion und gleich noch eine
größere dieses lager erschüttert und das
ist die taktik das ist genau die taktik
die ukraine seit einigen jahren seit
einigen tagen erst jetzt mit dem mega
explosion hier fahren dass man
systematisch sämtliche russische
waffenlager hinter der hinter der front
weit hinter der front zerstört dieses
waffenlager wie schon gesagt das
besondere nur zweieinhalb kilometer
entfernt von der russischen grenze wir
sehen dass jetzt gleich wenn die kamera
hier herauszoomen
dass wir also dass wir also bereits hier
ab hier ist russisches gebiet und hier
ist noch ukrainisches gebiet was von
russland besetzt wird
sofern jetzt ist der ukraine möglich mit
diesem präzisionswaffen eben sehr sehr
nah an der grenze zuzuschlagen ja wir
gucken in den süden des landes in der
region sagt büscher und bis zum
tatsächlich erschreckender aufnahmen wir
sehen brennende felder und nicht etwa
zufällig brennende felder nicht etwa
durch durch waldbrände erzeugte brenne
bäder oder durch zufällige beschuss
sondern absichtlich in brand gesteckte
felder das ist an diesen mustern hier
ziemlich gut zu erkennen wir haben wir
haben hier einmal ein brandherd wo wir
sehen das so zu sagen dass kreisförmig
hier feuer lodern und wir sehen das
ganze unter weiter ahnung wir sehen wir
die kamera dann nach links schwingt und
wie jetzt hier
ein ein weiterer brandherd ein weiteres
feld trennt und immer wieder diese
kleinen feuer diesel oder einen kleinen
feuer wir sehen also das ist kein zufall
dass sind so sicher attacken auf
ukrainische bauern auf ukrainische
felder um natürlich die nahrungszufuhr
sowohl für die ukraine als auch für die
vor allem in afrika lebenden kunden der
ukrainer die in sehr dringend angewiesen
sind auf dieses getreide diese
nahrungszufuhr zu zu unterlassen oder
eben abzuschneiden hunger als waffe
sowohl gegen die ukraine als auch gegen
den afrikanischen kunden und eben
hungernden menschen in afrika die von
der ukraine abhängig sind als allerdings
das wollen wir uns neue aufnahmen
ansehen die uns aus dem westen des
landes besonders sogar noch aus polen in
der nacht kurz vor der ukrainischen
grenze erreicht haben das sind
sogenannte krapp
selbstfahrer fetten oder oder japan zu
haubitzen aber nicht aus deutschland
nicht die panzerhaubitze 2000 sondern
die hanse cup aus polen die unter
anderem eigentlich in süd korea
hergestellt wird polen hat der ukraine
18 stück davon bisher geliefert als eine
art geschenk ja so wie es deutschland
auch macht mit denen mit der
panzerhaubitze 2000 aber und das ist
eben ganz anders polen hat weitere 50
stück weitere 50 stück dann der ukraine
verkauft also als ganz normales geschäft
zwischen zwei ländern bezahlt natürlich
von eu und usa also nicht von der
ukraine selbst kann sich im krieg das
gerade nicht leisten aber das besondere
ist eben dass davon jetzt 50 stück
gerade die ersten offenbar auf dem weg
sind in die ukraine und somit ja am ende
sechs mal sieben mal mehr da sein werden
als aus deutschland die panzer die diese
panzerhaubitze mitnahmen fast so gut wie
die deutsche hat etwa zehn kilometer
mehr reichweite hat vier schuss weniger
pro minute aber ist ähnlich präzise und
diese panzerhaubitzen aus polen sollen
so die hoffnung in warschau kiew das
blatt wenden und der ukraine entlang der
gesamten form von über 1.100 km
irgendwann auch die möglichkeit geben
die mit moderner westlicher artillerie
auch abzudecken und die russen hier zu
kämpfen